[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: I am really excited
to introduce our next keynote
speaker.
Sydney Chaffee is the 2017
National Teacher of the Year.
And that she was awarded--
we actually had the
opportunity to see
that award being presented
to her at the White House
earlier this year.
She's fantastic.
I've heard her
once before and was
thrilled to be able to
invite her to join us.
She's actually flown all the way
out from Boston just for today
and is headed off
tomorrow to space camp
as part of the National Teacher
of the Year Award program.
Sydney has been a ninth
grade humanities teacher
at Codman Academy Public
Charter School in Boston
for the past nine years.
In the classroom, she strives to
create lessons that demonstrate
how education can be
a transformative tool
for social justice, and
she encourages her students
to see themselves as having
the power to make change
in the world based on some
lessons from the past.
She tries to infuse
the hard work
of learning with joy not
only in her classroom
but throughout the school.
For example, she's
the coordinator
of a school-wide community
circle every Thursday
where all students in
the school come together
to celebrate successes,
share good news,
and dig in to serious
conversations together.
As the National
Teacher of the Year,
Sydney is focusing on education
as a tool for social justice,
the value of theater
and the arts,
and the importance of educators
taking instructional risks
to reach every student.
Please join me in
welcoming Sydney.
[APPLAUSE]
SYDNEY CHAFFEE: OK, good?
Hi.
You guys are fun.
This is fun.
These are fun.
All right, so I'm
going to use my notes
because I'm new at this.
I'm like a month into being
full time national teacher
of the year, and I don't have
my speeches memorized yet.
But I want to thank you
all for having me here.
I just want to
preface this by saying
that when I arrived today and
I was happily eating my lunch,
AT came over and he was
like, hey, just so you know,
before lunch, we
have the best speaker
I've ever seen in my life.
But, you know, no pressure.
Just try to be not too bad.
You won't be as good as him.
So here I am, thank you.
I'm really excited.
All right, so I want
to talk to you today
about Vincent van Gogh--
just because.
So in September 1882,
van Gogh sent a letter
to his younger brother Theo.
And he wrote, "I long so much
to make beautiful things.
But beautiful things require
effort and disappointment
and perseverance."
And van Gogh knew a thing or two
about effort and disappointment
and perseverance.
He struggled with
mental illness.
And although he was obviously
a really talented artist,
he was dismissed as insane.
His brilliant paintings
didn't make him any money,
and he relied on Theo, who was
four years younger than him,
to support him financially
so he could afford
to buy paint and canvases.
But he didn't give up.
Case in point.
So painting was
van Gogh's passion.
He was driven to it despite
the adversity that he faced.
He believed there was power in
pigments and canvases and brush
strokes.
And he explained
to Theo, "The great
doesn't happen
through impulse alone
and is a succession
of little things
that are brought together."
And when I was
thinking about what
I wanted to say to
you all here today,
that idea stuck with me-- that
greatness or change doesn't
just happen because
we want them to,
but because we work toward
them incrementally I'm
reminded of that lesson
again and again as a teacher.
Teaching is really
humbling work when
we realize that as much as
we want a student to grasp
a concept or master a new skill,
their brains work and develop
at their own pace.
Sometimes it takes one
explanation and they've got it.
Sometimes we have to go over
it again and again and again
and model it and reteach
it and think of a new way
and think of a really
clever analogy,
and then maybe they'll get it.
There's no one right way
to get to that end point.
And more often than not, we're
going to mess up a few times
before we get there.
But if we can remember
van Gogh's doggedness
in his own journey, I think
there are lessons for us there.
So he also wrote to Theo, "Even
if one loses here and there,
and even if one sometimes
feels a sort of decline,
the point is nevertheless
to revive and have courage,
even though things don't turn
out as one first thought."
And I feel like that perfectly
sums up our work sometimes.
So often, just like
van Gogh explained,
things don't turn out
exactly the way we planned,
but we persist because we
know that all of our students
deserve opportunities
to learn and grow.
To me, one of the most beautiful
things about being an educator
is that every single day, we
are surrounded by amazing people
and their amazing minds.
And we walk among this
constant source of inspiration
in our work.
We're surrounded by
colleagues, by peers
and by students who are
incredible, brilliant people.
And they remind us that
even though the work is hard
and the work sometimes
feels impossible,
we have to be relentless.
We have to believe that we as
individuals can make a huge
impact on our students
and by extension--
and this was said a little
while ago and I loved it--
the world.
We can change the world
through our actions.
During my first
year of teaching,
there was this
10th grade student
named Sheron who reminded me
of the power one individual
can have.
At that time my
school's uniform policy
required that all students had
to wear black or khaki pants.
Students who showed up to school
in jeans or shorts or skirts
had to change in order to be
allowed to come into class.
So 10th grade Sheron was a
force to be reckoned with.
She was super smart.
She was outspoken.
She had incredible
leadership skills.
And all throughout the previous
year as a ninth grader,
she'd shown up to
school every day
wearing black or khaki pants--
following the uniform policy.
But that September when she
turned into a 10th grader,
she showed up and she was
wearing a floor length khaki
skirt.
She told her teachers that
her religion required women
to wear skirts, not pants.
And that she was tired of
breaking with her faith
to follow the school's rule.
She liked the school, she said.
She just didn't
want to wear pants.
So her teachers consulted
with school administrators
and told her that,
unfortunately, she was not
permitted to be in pants--
whoops, no, she
was not permitted
to be in class unless
she was in uniform,
unless she was wearing pants.
So that day, she sat
outside in the hallway
and did all of her work.
She stayed the whole
day wearing her skirt,
doing her work out of uniform.
The next day, she showed up
again in another floor length
khaki skirt.
Again, she was told to change.
She refused and she did
her work in the hallway.
The administrators who
made the call saw this
as a really simple issue--
uniform policy called for pants.
Sheron was not
following that policy.
Case closed.
But the situation
didn't sit right
with a lot of other people.
Having an eager student
sitting in the hallway all day
just because she
was wearing a skirt,
especially because
it was out of a sense
of religious obligation,
felt contrary to our values
as an institution.
It felt like it went against
the reasons we worked with kids.
The reasons we were educators.
We wanted to value
who they were.
We wanted to show them
that they mattered.
And instead, we had her
sitting in the hall.
And the students weren't
happy about it either.
They called us out.
They told us we were hypocrites.
You know how they do.
They threatened that they would
show up in solidarity skirts.
They would call our bluff.
You can't keep us all
out of class, they said.
It's not fair, they said.
The rule is stupid, they said.
And over lunch and after
classes, a lot of us
thought that they
might be right.
They might have a point.
At our school, we pride
ourselves on our approach
to teaching history.
We use an interdisciplinary
humanities model
to weave stories from history
together with literacy skills,
and we center our curricula
on the idea of social justice.
During her ninth grade
year, the year before,
Sheron had studied the history
of apartheid in South Africa.
And she and her classmates
had looked at the ways
that South Africans
had resisted apartheid.
She knew about
civil disobedience--
the idea that protesting
an unjust rule
by peacefully breaking it and
accepting the consequences
could create change.
And she knew about that
because teachers at our school
had taught her about it.
So day after day, Sheron
showed up in a skirt,
embodying the principles
of civil disobedience.
And day after day, the
school punished her for it
because we had tied ourselves
to a rigid rule in a handbook.
Sheron and her friends began
circulating a petition calling
for a religious
exemption to be written
into the uniform policy.
They gathered the signature
of almost every single person
in the school-- students and
staff and administrators.
And so one night, they packed
into a classroom-- students,
staff, family members,
and Sheron in her skirt--
for the monthly
school board meeting,
which was usually
sparsely attended and not
at all on students' radars.
At the meeting, Sheron presented
the petition and made her case.
The board members listened and
they approved the exemption.
And looking back, it
makes sense that the board
voted to make the change.
It was undeniably
the right change
to make to an unjust rule.
So then why had it
taken all of the adults
so long to come around?
I think sometimes as adults,
we default to the logic
of our brains instead of
the logic of our hearts.
And if there are any biology
teachers in the room,
forgive me, because
you're probably
cringing at this clearly
nonscientific exploration
of anatomy, but I
started out as a poet
and sometimes I have to do
these things, so I'm sorry.
So brain logic said that
the rule was the rule,
and Sheron and her
family had signed papers
agreeing to follow the rules.
And so she had to
follow the rules,
and that was the end
of it, case closed.
Brain logic said if the rule
was bent for one student,
it would have to be bent
for everyone and chaos would
ensue--
whatever chaos looks
like when students
choose their own
clothing, I don't know.
Brain logic said she had worn
pants the entire year previous,
and so she should just
keep wearing them.
But heart logic was
like, hey, guys--
because heart logic
is more casual.
Heart logic was like,
hey, guys, here's
a kid who really
wants to learn, who's
showing up to school every day
and completing her assignments.
And we're holding her out of
class because of her clothing,
which she wears, by the
way, because of her faith.
Heart logic said
this doesn't feel
right even though
technically it might be OK.
Heart logic said rules
aren't as important as making
sure this kid feels safe
and welcome here every day.
Heart logic changes minds.
For the past few
years, we've had
students who wear skirts and
hijabs to school every day.
And unbeknownst to
them, their ability
to dress in accordance to their
religious beliefs at our school
is due to Sheron, a
student they've never met.
A student who's now an adult
and, just as a side note,
is now an educator.
Because of Sheron's insistence
that the school walk
the walk of social justice,
that it live and breathe
on our policies and not
just in our curricula,
our handbook now contains rules
that are more just and more
responsive to our community.
Because of Sheron,
other students
have since organized themselves
to successfully advocate
for revising the uniform
policy over the last 10 years.
Because of Sheron, we
now have conversations
as a staff about whether
the policy still serves us
as a school community or whether
it reflects our values at all.
And all of those changes began
with one student's action.
As van Gogh wrote, "The great
doesn't happen through impulse
alone and is a succession
of little things
that are brought together."
One person can set those
little things into motion.
As educators, we wholly
believe in our students' power
and ability.
We wouldn't do this
work if we didn't.
We wouldn't be here in the
summer if we didn't, right?
We care about it.
We know that it matters.
We know our students
are powerful.
But often when it comes
to believing in ourselves,
in our own power and
ability as educators,
we do not give ourselves the
same benefit of the doubt.
We don't have confidence in
our own ability to make change.
We think, I'm just one person.
There isn't enough time.
But imagine if we
re-conceptualized
what leadership looks like.
Sometimes we have this mythical
image of the capital L, Leader,
in our minds.
They stand out in
front of everyone else.
They have a fancy title.
They have a business card, maybe
it's got color on one side.
They've been in the
game a really long time.
They know everything
there is to know.
People trust them implicitly.
They usher people
and organizations
through great changes
because they have vision.
But in practice, great leaders
don't all look the same.
They don't all look like that.
We know that.
There is no archetype.
Some great leaders are
great collaborators.
They're excellent listeners.
They delegate.
They empower.
One of the ideas that's always
stuck with me that I aspire to
is that great leaders
make themselves obsolete.
Great leaders create
other great leaders.
That's one of the
reasons why I think
it's so amazing that we
have principals here today,
by the way.
So I want us to
rethink leadership
as something that can
be held collaboratively
by all of the
people in this room
or by all the people
in the school.
Calling ourselves leaders
doesn't mean that we have it
all figured out.
I call myself a teacher leader,
but I'm not a perfect teacher.
If you walk into my classroom
any day of the week,
you're going to see me
struggling with problems.
You're going to see me
trying to figure out how
to engage a reluctant reader.
You're going to
see me figuring out
how to support an
English language
learner in literary
analysis, how
to get a kid with
oppositional defiance disorder
to stay in the classroom
and learn and feel valued.
I make a lot of
mistakes, and I still
battle self-doubt
that tells me I'm
not worthy of that
title of leader,
that I don't have anything
good to tell anybody else.
But over the years,
I've started to expand
my definition of leadership
to include things
like encouraging
vulnerability in others
by opening my own classroom
door and welcoming feedback.
To me, leadership can mean
collaborating with people
who make me smarter
and more courageous,
but who might not
have as many chances
as I have to get out there
and have their voices heard.
Leadership means
being the one to start
an uncomfortable but necessary
conversation among the staff
about how we can do better.
Leadership means
nurturing skills
of leadership in other people,
including our students.
Leadership means
believing, like Sheron did,
that even a small
action on our part
might be the thing that
causes a big change.
Educators need to
get comfortable
seeing ourselves as leaders.
We can have influence far
beyond our individual classrooms
if we remind ourselves
that we define
what leadership looks like, and
that one person's actions can
have wide reaching consequences.
An aside-- when I
was a little kid,
I did a short-lived
stint as a ballerina.
It only lasted a little
while, and then I
quit because the teacher
wouldn't let me wear pink.
No, no, she said I
had to wear pink.
I couldn't wear purple
and blue, and I really
wanted to wear purple and blue.
I wanted to be me, but she
wouldn't let me so I quit.
But before I quit,
there was this recital.
And because I was
tall, she put me
in charge of leading
one of the groups.
So what was going to happen
was that the two groups were
going to come out of the wings.
We're going to do this sort
of elegant ballet-like gallop.
And I was going to lead
one group galloping,
and this other girl was going
to lead this other group.
We're going to gallop out.
So here we are.
It's the day of the recital,
and I'm wearing my pink.
And I come galloping out
of the side very elegantly.
I come galloping out,
leading my group of girls.
And I get onstage, and I'm
supposed to lead them around
in a circle.
And then something else
is supposed to happen,
but it just leaves my head.
I go completely blank.
And so I'm galloping
and galloping,
and everyone's following me.
And I catch the eye--
but it looks good.
It looks really good.
I catch the eye of the girl
who was leading the other team.
It's not what it's
supposed to be.
And then I catch the
eye of the girl who's
leading the other team,
and I'm like, all right,
I'm just going to
do what she does.
So she leads her circle around,
so I lead my circle around.
And then she leads
her circle around,
and I lead my circle around.
And we end up going around
and around and around
until the teacher comes out
galloping, not elegantly,
and she sort of
stops everything.
And she's like, hold on.
And she apologizes
to the audience,
which is like the
worst thing ever
if you're performing to have
someone be like, I'm sorry.
And she huddles us up and
she says, what happened?
And I looked at her and
I was like, I forgot.
So I was following her.
And the other girl was like,
well, I was following you.
And so I say that
to say, if we aren't
going to be the ones
to step up and be
the leaders in our
schools, then who is?
We're just going
to be following.
We're going in circles
around and around and around.
And so at some point, we've got
to sort of step up and be like,
all right, I'm going to
gallop this thing off
in some sort of direction to at
least get us going somewhere.
We all need to see
ourselves as leaders.
We all need to be
brave in the face
of seeming impossibilities.
And in order to do
that, we need to work
within school communities that
encourage collaboration that
say it's OK to take
risks, that we're going
to learn from our mistakes.
We need to have the freedom
and the support to innovate.
We need to listen to brain
logic and heart logic.
And when all teachers are able
to see ourselves as leaders,
as members of a powerful
collective of people who
care about doing
the best work we can
on behalf of our
students, we take
risks that have big payoffs.
We try new techniques.
We partner with people
we otherwise wouldn't.
We feel a sense of
personal responsibility
for what happens in our schools.
And we are relentless in
advocating for the changes
our students need.
We don't allow
fumbles or missteps
to deter us from
our ultimate mission
of getting every student
in our schools to succeed.
We shift the cultures
of our schools
away from closed doors
and hidden struggles
towards collaboration
and honesty.
We remember that
change takes time.
In October 1883, van Gogh wrote
his brother Theo a long letter.
The letter implies that Theo was
having doubts about his career.
Theo was an art dealer, but
he was getting frustrated.
And he wondered if
maybe he should just
go into the business
of art itself--
if he should try his
hand at being an artist
like his brother, but he
had doubts about whether he
was cut out for it.
So van Gogh gave
him what I think
is some of the most beautiful
advice ever written.
He says, "If you hear a
voice within you saying,
you are not a painter, then
by all means paint, boy,
and that voice will be
silenced, but only by working."
This year, you have the
opportunity to be painters.
You have the opportunity to
be leaders within your schools
and effect changes that reach
beyond just one classroom.
So what kind of schools
can you envision?
What kind of masterpieces
might you create?
There are incredible things
happening in our schools,
and there is so much
more on the horizon.
Our students, our Sherons,
and all the other ones--
they're brave.
And when they discover
their leadership potential,
they can change the world.
We need to learn that
bravery from them.
Inspired by our students
and for our students,
we have to be leaders.
And by all means,
we have to paint.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So I'm a teacher, and I'm going
to ask you to do some writing
and thinking and talking.
And then you're going to talk to
me, and it's going to be great.
So I'm going to
ask you on your own
to write or think about
these two questions--
what beautiful things do you
want to create at your school?
So van Gogh said he longed so
much to make beautiful things,
but he knew that
beautiful things required
effort and determination.
So what beautiful things do you
want to create at your school,
and what stands in your way?
And you already did
the [INAUDIBLE]..
So try to spend more time on
the first half than the second.
We're just going to take two
minutes for you to write,
and then I'm going
to ask you to talk.
So I know that you're
sitting with your principal.
So pair up with
not your principal.
It could be somebody else
at your table, somebody
else nearby.
Pair up and I'm
going to give you
three minutes just to share
with one another what you wrote.
I'll tell you when a minute
and a half has gone by.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
OK, so before we move
on to the next step,
I would love to hear some
of the beautiful things.
So what are a couple
of the beautiful things
that you envision
happening at your school?
AUDIENCE: I'd like to
see parent involvement
in our middle school,
because we do not
have PTA or PTO or any
parent organization.
I would like to see that evolve
through this mission somehow.
SYDNEY CHAFFEE: Nice.
Anyone agree with
that, poetry snobs?
All right, who else?
Beautiful things?
AUDIENCE: I'd like to create
an environment for teachers
to be risk takers-- for them
to be comfortable doing that.
SYDNEY CHAFFEE: She wants to
create an environment where
teachers can be
risk takers, where
there's an
environment where they
feel comfortable doing that.
Awesome.
AUDIENCE: Teachers who bring
joy to their classrooms.
SYDNEY CHAFFEE: Teachers who
bring joy to their classrooms.
Can I hear two more?
AUDIENCE: Teachers who want
to make their jobs easier
by facilitating the
students' learning
rather than telling the
student what they should learn.
SYDNEY CHAFFEE: Ah,
teachers who want
to make their jobs easier by
facilitating students' learning
rather than telling
students what to learn.
And right there.
AUDIENCE: Thinking
about something
that was on yours--
students who take
charge of their own learning.
SYDNEY CHAFFEE:
Beautiful, students
who take charge of
their own learning.
All right, so we've
already looked
at this today, the sort
of concentric circle idea.
And mine is less pretty
than the Google Slides,
but I'm working on it.
But I want you to think about
how you might re-envision
your own leadership to make
some of those beautiful things
possible, right.
So we talked about the ripple
effect earlier with you
in the center, and
then moving out
from you are sort of
these concentric circles
of influence, right.
Or these concentric
circles of, well,
who can you
immediately influence?
Who might they influence?
How might that spread
from there, right?
The one we looked at earlier
said, self, school, world,
I believe.
So you can work on this
individually or with the person
you were just talking
to, but I want
you to think a bit about, OK, if
that's the beautiful thing you
want to create, how might
you be able to re-envision
your own leadership
to make that happen?
Who do you immediately
have influence
on, or who do you immediately
have sort of an effect on,
or what realm in your school
do you have an effect on?
And then how does it
move out from there?
How far could your
influence reach, OK?
So you don't have to
have all the answers,
but I want you to
just think about it.
We're going to do five
minutes to think on this.
So again, either alone or with
the person you were talking to.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
OK.
So at my school, every
year, we take our kids
to this camp in New Hampshire
called Camp Merrowvista.
And my kids are city
kids so they really
think they're roughing it.
But there are cabins, and
they're heated and whatever.
But one of the things
we do at Merrowvista
is they get into
this place where
they feel like they
can do anything,
and they're in this
really good headspace,
and they're looking
forward to the year ahead.
And so we ask them to set
intentions for the year.
So we ask them to
think about, OK,
if you are going to be this
person that you're here
at Camp Merrowvista,
if you were going
to be this person for the rest
of the year, what would that
look like?
And so earlier, we looked at
an analogy of a road trip.
And we talked about
what's more important
than the vehicle is the goal.
So I actually want to think
about this intention as like--
I was sitting back there
trying to figure out
what the appropriate thing
in the analogy would be.
And it was a long flight,
and I don't really know.
But what I came
up with was that I
want you to think about
your intention as the snacks
and the music that you
need in order to make
the trip in the first place.
So your intention
is not your goal.
It's not something
that you can check off
at the end of the year and
be like, yes, I did it.
Your intention is the way that
you're going to be this year.
So if we're thinking
about, OK, you
want to create these
beautiful things that you just
talked about, you
want to re-envision
your own leadership, you
want to think about yourself
as the middle of
that ripple effect.
What is the way
that you have to be?
What is the way that you have
to live or exist in your school
or as a leader in order
to make that possible?
And so I want you
to think about that.
And we always have our kids
start it out by saying,
this year my intention is,
and it's like one sentence.
So again, it's not
a goal, but how
do you want to be this year.
It's something that you can keep
coming back to again and again,
even when you mess up--
because you will,
because we all do--
to remind yourself,
oh, yeah, this
is how I wanted to
be this year to make
beautiful things happen.
So take a couple
of minutes and try
to articulate an intention that
you might have for this year.
And then we'll have some
time to share them out.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
All right, so I'd
like to hear these.
I'd like for you to use your
teacher voices, all right.
So I'd like to hear a bunch
of them if you could stand up.
Tell us your name because
I don't know your name.
And tell us your
intention for the year.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my
name is [INAUDIBLE]..
And this year, my
intention is to be
to be a valuable asset
to all staff members.
SYDNEY CHAFFEE: I like that.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm
Stephanie, and my intention
is to have a growth
mindset with myself.
SYDNEY CHAFFEE: Nice.
AUDIENCE: My name's
[INAUDIBLE],, and this year, I
want to be an assertive
leader to the staff,
being apathetic,
genuine, just serve them
where they don't feel
like I'm on top of them,
that I'm underneath them.
SYDNEY CHAFFEE: Ah, nice.
AUDIENCE: My intention
as part of the program
is to be a listener
and a connector,
to really hear what's going
on with people-- what's
going well, what challenges
there are, and help people
create [INAUDIBLE].
SYDNEY CHAFFEE: Nice.
I would like to hear
three more and I'll wait.
AUDIENCE: My name
is Darlene Jackson
and this year my intention
is to empower teachers.
SYDNEY CHAFFEE: Mm-hmm.
Short and sweet--
empower teachers.
I like that.
AUDIENCE: My intention--
my name's Mike.
My intention is to create
opportunities for the students
to empower themselves.
SYDNEY CHAFFEE: I love that.
AUDIENCE: I am April, and
this year my intention
is stay focused and committed
to the process regardless
of obstacles.
SYDNEY CHAFFEE: Nice, did
you guys hear that over here?
Stay focused and committed
to the process regardless
of obstacles.
Nice, I know I had
one in the back.
AUDIENCE: I thought you
wanted us to come up
with a journey and a snack.
In my mind, I thought of
margaritas and Doritos.
[LAUGHING]
Margaritas and Doritos to
spice it up in our school.
SYDNEY CHAFFEE: No, I like that.
I like that.
She made it her own.
Margaritas on a road
trip, I don't know.
All right, anyone else?
My principal does this thing.
Principals don't do this thing.
My principal does this
thing where it will
be in a full staff meeting--
I love my principal, so
I can make fun of him--
and then he'll be like,
OK, any last burnings?
And then no one else
ever says anything,
because you don't want to be the
one who has the last burning.
So any last burnings?
No?
OK, well that's all
I have for you today.
If you are
interested, I'm trying
to up my social media game,
because my students told me
I had to.
The top one is Twitter, the
bottom one is Instagram.
I made the Instagram so my
kids could follow my journey,
because they told
me to join Snapchat
and I said I'm too old for that.
So anyway that's me if
you want to follow me.
And then I have a
few minutes left
if there's anyone who has any
questions about space camp
or me or anything else.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Where are
you going for that?
SYDNEY CHAFFEE: Where am
I going for space camp?
To the moon-- no, we're
going to Huntsville, Alabama.
[CHEERING]
Oh, hey, OK, I need
to talk to you guys.
OK, I need to
connect with you guys
later, because all of the
state teachers of the year
will be there next
week or tomorrow,
and we're looking
for a karaoke bar.
So get back to us.
Any other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What teacher had
an impact on your life?
SYDNEY CHAFFEE: Oh,
that's a great question.
What teacher had an
impact on my life.
So the first teacher that had
an impact on my life was my mom.
My mom went back to
college on the day
that I started kindergarten.
So she put me in the
car, drove me to school,
and went back to get her degree.
And so growing up,
she was a feminist.
She was a working mom,
and she was a student.
And eventually when
she got her degree,
then she got her
masters, she went back
and she was an
adjunct professor.
And so growing up, I had this
strong woman in my house,
and the message that I got
was that that was good,
and that that was normal,
and that was natural,
and that education
was really important.
And it was worth juggling
all of these things
to have that education.
And that there's no one path.
There are lots of different
ways to get where we're going.
So she was my first,
most important teacher.
In college, I had a
teacher named Lyde Sizer.
I went to Sarah
Lawrence, and Lyde Sizer
is the daughter of Ted Sizer--
famous ed reformer who
started the coalition
of essential schools.
He wrote this book
"Horace's Compromise."
And I decided in college,
I'm going to be a professor.
So I had gone to
college to be a poet.
And then my poetry teacher
told me that I probably
shouldn't be a poet.
And I guess--
[LAUGHTER]
I guess he's like, I
don't know, an expert
because he got a Pulitzer
for poetry the other year.
So I was like, OK,
what am I going to do?
I'm not going to be a poet.
And so I was studying women's
history with Lyde Sizer.
And I was studying
writing, but not poetry.
And I was trying
to figure out what
I was going to do with my life.
And then I had this epiphany.
And I was like, I'm
going to be a professor.
I'm going to be a professor
at Sarah Lawrence.
I'm going to stay here forever,
because I love it here.
And I'll do for people
what you've done
for me-- it was very beautiful.
So I go into her office
and I'm like, that's what
I'm going to do.
And she was like, OK, calm down.
You know, you're
20, you're not going
to be a professor next year.
And she sent me off to her
father's school in the Bronx--
coalition school.
And it was my first
experience, not as
a high school student myself,
being in a classroom again
and watching what was
happening and having that sort
of outsider perspective.
And I decided that I wanted
to teach younger people
and maybe not be a professor.
And then I went to
SummerBridge, which
is now called Breakthrough
Collaborative, for a summer.
And then I did Citizen
Schools in Boston,
and then I ended up
at my current school.
But she really set me on
that path of saying, OK,
there are models out there.
Let me show you.
And she influenced me.
Also, just because I
wanted to be here because
she was a great teacher.
She made me think,
and I always wanted
her to believe in my ideas.
And I knew she did
believe in my ideas,
but she also was the
type of teacher who
would just push me and
push me to say, OK,
but what about this?
OK, let's dig deeper on that.
And she asked really
great questions.
She made me think.
Any questions?
SPEAKER 1: All right,
well if that's the end,
we want to thank Sydney again.
Thank you so much
for being here.
[APPLAUSE]